>>> I'M BACK N WITH OUR CHIEF
INTERNATIONAL CORRESPOENT,
CLARISSA WARD.
SHE WAS THERE FOR THE HANDOFF OF
THE REMAINS OF AMERICAN VETERAN
JOSHUA JONES IN UKRAINE TODAY.
CLARISSA DOCUMENTS THE RETURN OF
THE TENNESSEE NATIVE WHO WERE
RETURNED TO UKRAINE BACK IN
AUGUST.
>> ON THE FRONTLINES OF UKRAINE,
HE WAS KNOWN TO HIS FELLOW
FIGHTERS AS TACTICAL JESUS, ON
ACCOUNT OF HIS LONG HAIR AND
DEEP KNOWLEDGE OF THE BIBLE.
TO HIS MOM, HE WAS SIMPLY JOSHY.
TENNESSEE NATIVE JOSHUA JONES
WAS JUST 24 YEARS OLD WHEN HE
WAS KILLED FIGHTING IN EASTERN
UKRAINE BACK IN AUGUST.
HIS PASSPORT AND UKRAINIAN
MILITARY ID SHOWED UP ON RUSSIAN
SOCIAL MEDIA CHANNELS SOON
AFTER, BUT HIS BODY WAS NEVER
RECOVERED.
SINCE THEN, UKRAINIAN LAWMAKERS
HAVE WORKED TIRELESSLY TO GET
HIS BODY BACK.
AND TODAY, IT IS FINALLY
HAPPENING.
WHY IS IT IMPORTANT TO YOU TO
RECOVER THE BODY OF JOSHUA
JONES?
>> HE WAS FOR ME, OUR SOLDIERS.
WE SHOULD MAKE EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO GIVE HIS BODY BACK
TO HIS FAMILY.
>> Reporter: WE ARE DRIVING TO
THE FRONT LINE IN ZAPORIZHZHIA.
WE STOP ALONG THE WAY TO LINK UP
WITH MILITARY INTELLIGENCE.
IN ANOTHER CAR, A RUSSIAN
SOLDIER SITS SLUMPED OVER.
HE IS BEING RELEASED TODAY AS
PART OF A LARGER SWAP IN WHICH
TEN UKRAINIANS WERE ALREADY
FREED.
THE LAWMAKERS TALK WITH THE
OFFICERS TO GO OVER THE PLAN
ONCE MORE.
A MAKESHIFT WHITE FLAG IS PUT
TOGETHER FOR THE MOMENT OF
TRANSFER.
AND WE'RE OFF AGAIN, THIS TIME
TO NO MAN'S LAND.
A RARE TWO-HOUR CEASEFIRE HAS
BEEN AGREED BY BOTH SIDES, AND
TIME IS OF THE ESSENCE.
SO WE'VE JUST ARRIVED AT THE
MEETING POINT.
THEY'RE WAITING FOR THE RUSSIANS
TO ARRIVE WITH THE BODY.
>> A TEAM OF FORENSIC
INVESTIGATORS GET READY.
THIS IS AS FAR AS WE ARE ALLOWED
TO GO.
ACTUAL HANDOVER WILL HAPPEN JUST
BEYOND THE HILL.
WAITING FOR THEIR RETURN, IT IS
EERILY QUIET.
ONLY THE BRAVEST DARE COME OUT
IN THESE PARTS.
ONE OF THE TRANSFER TEAM
CAPTURES THE MOMENT JOSHUA
JONES' BODY IS BROUGHT BACK INTO
UKRAINIAN TERRITORY, AS RUSSIAN
FORCES LOOK ON.
IT'S THE MOMENT THEY HAVE BEEN
WAITING FOR.
JONES IS NOW ONE STEP CLOSER TO
BEING RETURNED TO HIS FAMILY.
BACK IN THE CAR, THEY SHOW US
HIS PERSONAL EFFECTS.
>> THIS IS HIS PERSONAL BODY
CROSS, WHICH HE WAS WEARING.
HE WAS A RELIGIOUS GUY.
>> WHAT'S YOUR FEELING IN THIS
MOMENT?
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING TOWARD THIS
FOR A LONG TIME TO TRY TO GET
JOSHUA JONES BACK TO HIS FAMILY.
>> WE ARE PROUD OF COUNTRY, OF
OUR TEAM.
WE ARE PROUD OF PRESIDENT.
AND WE ARE PROUD THAT WE ARE
SAVING LIVES BECAUSE, YOU KNOW,
EVEN WHEN SOMEBODY IS DYING, HIS
FAMILY CONTINUE TO LIVE.
AND THEY CANNOT LIVE NORMALLY IF
THEY KNOW THAT THEY DON'T HAVE A
PLACE WHERE TO COME FOR THEIR
SON.
>> Reporter: THANKS TO THEIR
EFFORTS, JOSHUA'S MOTHER, MISTY
GOSSETT IN TENNESSEE, WILL SOON
HAVE THE CHANCE TO SAY GOOD-BYE
TO HER SON.
>> JOSHUA WAS -- HE WAS A
SOLDIER.
HE WAS A BORN SOLDIER.
HE WAS NAMED AFTER THE BATTLE OF
JERICHO, AND HE PROVED HE LIVED
UP TO HIS NAME.
SO, VALIANTLY.
AND I FEEL LIKE THE WEIGHT OF
THE WORLD HAS BEEN LIFTED OFF OF
ME.
>> Reporter: A NAME AND A LIFE
THAT WILL BE REMEMBERED EVEN
HALF A WORLD AWAY.
JAKE, AT LEAST FIVE AMERICANS
HAVE BEEN KILLED FIGHTING HERE
IN UKRAINE.
AND THOSE TWO LAWMAKERS WE SPENT
THE DAY WITH SAID THERE ARE AT
LEAST TWO AMERICANS WHO ARE
STILL ALIVE WHO ARE BEING HELD
BY RUSSIAN FORCES.
THEY VERY MUCH HOPE THAT WHAT
YOU SAW TODAY COULD BE A PRELUDE
TO NEGOTIATING THEIR RELEASE AND
ALSO THE RELEASE OF MANY OF THE
OTHER NATIONALITIES WHO HAVE
COME TO UKRAINE TO JOIN THE
UKRAINIAN FOREIGN LEGION, TO
PARTICIPATE AND PLAY A ROLE IN
THIS WAR, JAKE.
>> CLARISSA, FIRST OF ALL, JUST
EXTRAORDINARY AND IMPACTFUL AND
EMOTIONAL JOURNALISM.
SO, THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT TO
US.
TAKE ME BACK TO THE MOMENT WHERE
YOU FIRST SAW JOSHUA'S BODY
BEING BROUGHT INTO UKRAINIAN
TERRITORY DURING THIS RARE
TWO-HOUR-LONG CEASEFIRE?
HOW TENSE WAS IT?
>> IT WAS VERY TENSE, JAKE.
IT WAS TENSE FROM THE MOMENT WE
ARRIVED.
THE MILITARY INTELLIGENCE PEOPLE
WHO WE WERE WITH WERE QUITE
NERVOUS.
THEY WERE CONCERNED ABOUT OUR
PRESENCE JUST BECAUSE THE
SITUATION ON THE GROUND WAS SO
TENUOUS AND NOBODY, I THINK, WAS
REALLY CONVINCED THAT THIS
TWO-HOUR CEASEFIRE WAS GOING TO
HOLD.
AND EVERYBODY WAS VERY CONCERNED
THAT THE TIMINGS WERE VERY
PRECISE.
AND IN FACT, BY THE WAY, THE
CEASEFIRE ENDED AT 3:00.
AND AT 3:10, THE AIR RAID SIRENS
STARTED GOING OFF ONCE AGAIN.
SO, I THINK THERE WAS A LOT OF
CONCERN ABOUT THE FACT THAT
THERE WERE SO MANY MOVING PARTS,
SO MANY THINGS THAT COULD GO
WRONG, AND THE FACT THAT YOU HAD
US AS JOURNALISTS ALONG
OBVIOUSLY ADDED A DIFFERENT
LAYER OF RESPONSIBILITY FOR
THEM.
IT WAS DEFINITELY TENSE, BUT
THEN THERE WAS THAT MOMENT OF
RELIEF WHEN THEY WERE ABLE TO
PUT THE BODY INTO THE AMBULANCE
AND